we are on problem
number
10.
see on page 49 stacy noted that she is
both the 12th tallest and the 12th
shortest
student in her class let me write 12th
the down she's the 12th tallest and
shortest
if everyone in the class is a different
height how many students are there in
the class and these are these are the
type of questions that i just like to
make sure that i'm not you know
miscounting right so she's the 12th
tallest so what does that mean that
means that there are 11
people
taller than her
right so let's say you know from
shortest
to tallest
so this is stacy right here you know
this stacy
and so if she is the 12th tallest
so let me let me put it this way if i
said that she was the if she was the
first tallest that means there's no one
taller than her if she's the second
tallest that means there's one person
taller than her if she's the third
tallest that means there's two people
taller than her and likewise if she's
the 12th tallest that means that there
are 11 people taller
eleven taller
eleven dollar
similarly if she's the twelfth shortest
well that means that must mean that
they're eleven shorter than her so this
is really just making sure that you kind
of parse the words correctly and count
properly so if there's 11 shorter 11
taller and then there's stacy well
that's 22 plus her there's 23 students
in the class and this is just to make
sure that you know you don't say oh 12
taller 12 shorter and say 25 or
something like that or
you know it's just to confuse you
really i think
okay problem number 11
image clear image invert colors problem
number eleven switch colors
eleven
the quadratic function g
is given by well this is just the
general way people write quadratic
functions is equal to
a x squared plus b x
plus c
where a and c are negative constants a
and c
are negative right negative constants
which of the following could be the
graph of g so i'm not going to even look
at the choices i'll just show you how i
would you know if someone didn't even
give me any choice and say well if a and
c are less than 0 what's this going to
look like
so let's draw the
x and y
so let's say that that is the x axis
actually i drew this in court let me
edit undo edit undo okay so let me draw
the x-axis
you might realize pretty soon why i drew
it i have to redo this the y-axis
right x
y
all right so we know that a and c are
negative so c is the y intercept right
when x is equal to 0 we're just left
with g of x is equal to c so c is the y
intercept so if c is less than 0 we know
that the y intercept is going to be
below the x axis it's going to be a
negative number so
we know that you know this is going to
be
this is c
is where the graph intersects the y axis
we also know it's going to be symmetric
around the y axis
because um we haven't really well
actually we don't know for sure that
it's going to be symmetric around the y
axis and i could i could go
into that in more detail but i won't but
that's all we need to know it depends
what the b x this term is but let's just
ignore that for now and then we know
that a is negative so in general it's
you might want to prove it to yourself
you know the graph of y equals x squared
that opens up like this and the graph of
y is equal to minus x squared
it goes down like that
right
so a possible graph for this would look
like this
all right the important thing is it has
to be a these are the two things that
you know when they tell you a and c is
negative it's going to be a graph that
opens downwards
and it's going to intersect the
y-intercept it's going to it's going to
intersect the y-axis but
in the negative
area or you know below the x-axis a
legitimate graph also would have looked
like this
it could have also looked like this
it didn't actually have to be symmetric
around it depends what this bx term does
but if we look at the choices the only
choice that
intercepts the y-axis
below the x-axis or in the you know at a
negative y intercept and opens down is
choice a i mean there's only three
choices that open down and only choice a
intercepts in the negative area so the
answer is a it actually looks eerily
like what i drew just out of the blue
next question
problem
number 12.
okay so they drew a square and i will
draw a square because they drew a square
and they say this is a this is
b
this is c
d
and this is
p
this is
q and out here is r i don't know where
this problem is going but it looks
interesting figure not drawn to scale of
course
in the figure above a b c d is a
rectangle with b c is equal to four
okay bc is equal four a b is equal to
six
p q and r are different points on a line
not shown that is parallel to a d
so p q and r
are apparently all on the same line
that is parallel to a d
i guess that is the way they drew it so
let me let me erase so let's just say q
so this let's say this is q
that r is down here right this isn't r
that's not so they're all on the same
line and they say the line isn't shown
but it's parallel it's parallel to a d
so let me draw that line so that line
looks something like this
we draw it straight
okay and on that line you have p
p
q and r and it is parallel to a d
good enough
it is parallel to a d
points p
and q
are symmetric about line a b
points p and q are symmetric about line
a b
okay so that means
that p and q are equidistant from this
line so that means that
that means that
this distance
is equal to this distance when they say
p and q are symmetric around a b you can
always pretend like a b is a mirror
right here and p and q are the mirror
images of each other good enough
and then it also says p and q are
symmetric about line a b and points q
and r
are symmetric around line
c d
so q and r are symmetric around line cd
so we also know
that
this distance
is equal to this distance
good enough
what is the length
of p
r
what is the length of pr
this is fascinating so let's say that
this length right here let me do it in
yellow
this length is x
right then what is this green length
going to be
well this green length right here is
going to be 4 minus x
4 minus x how did i know is 4 minus x
well this distance up here is 4
this distance up here is 4. so this is x
this is 4 minus x well then that this
distance right here is also going to be
4 minus x
well and if this yellow distance is x
then we also know that this distance is
x
so the distance from p to r is going to
be the sum of all of these right x plus
x plus 4 minus x plus 4 minus x
and i think you see where this is going
it's
x
plus x
plus 4 minus x plus 4 minus x
these x's all cancel out right 2x minus
2x
and we're just left with 8 and that's
our answer b
and you could have tried out now you
could assumed q was right in the middle
and it would have worked out the same
but this is you know you know for sure
that the answer is eight
next problem
image clear
invert i don't have time for this the
price i get nervous when i'm running out
of time so i'm gonna do this in the next
video see you soon